Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis de retour pour quelques vidéos dans ce bureau là.
Partout où je vais je vous emmène avec moi.
Hier soir peu avant minuit, on a passé ensemble, c'était un travail d'équipe,
les 200 000 personnes qui suivent la chaîne.
Juste un truc de ouf !
Je vous en reparle à la fin de la vidéo.
Il y a un peu plus de 6 mois de ça je vous avais parlé de 7 techniques de manipulation,
pour pouvoir les détecter et surtout les contrer,
savoir comment réagir en fonction de ça.
Et bien aujourd'hui je vous fais la suite de cette vidéo
Gé-gé-gé Générique !
*musique du générique*
Petite précision quand même par rapport à la manipulation.
Elle n'est pas toujours faite consciemment de la personne qui est en face de vous.
C'est aussi un moyen parfois d'argumenter,
d'essayer d'obtenir ce qu'on veut.
Mais c'est pas forcément très machiavélique, c'est pas tout à fait réfléchi.
Donc si vous en détectez une, n'hésitez pas à faire ce qu'on appelle un pont d'or,
c'est à dire vous la cassez, mais vous ne culpabilisez pas la personne en face
vous essayez juste de remettre la conversation dans un bon rail,
sur quelque chose de plus concret.
Vous laissez une deuxième chance à la personne.
La première technique dont je vais vous parler c'est ce qu'on appelle la perspective piégée.
Imaginons qu'il y a un choix à faire.
Avant de faire ce choix on pourrait établir une liste avec des avantages et des inconvénients.
Mais si moi je veux que vous ne fassiez pas ce choix là,
que vous refusiez
alors je vais vous présenter un petit avantage et beaucoup d'inconvénients.
En clair je vais déformer la balance, elle ne va pas être objective.
Donc quand on vous présente des avantages et des inconvénients
pensez à l'objectivité. N'hésitez pas à demander à la personne d'étoffer celles qu'elle a négligées
et d'un point de vue plus général gardez l'esprit critique,
pour voir si la personne n'est pas en train d'essayer simplement d'argumenter sa thèse à elle.
C'est souvent une thèse non dite.
Deuxième technique de manipulation bien connue de nos amis les médias,
La fausse corrélation entre A et B.
Faire un rapport entre deux choses qui n'ont rien à voir ensemble
et te le vendre comme si c'était lié.
Si j'avais eu assez de temps pour ça je vous aurai fait une courbe de progression
du nombre d'abonnés sur la chaîne du mental vlog cette année
et en parallèle, et en rapport je vous aurait fait une courbe de progression du nombre de vente du pot de mayonnaise, de cette année.
En cherchant bien on peut trouver un rapport.
Alors que vous et moi on sait qu'il n'y a pas de rapport entre les deux.
Parfois c'est moins flagrant.
Les manipulateurs dans ce cas, mettent en rapport deux choses qui n'ont pas de sens
qui n'ont pas de lien direct
ou qui omettent un troisième facteur C ou un quatrième facteur D
qui expliquent en fait pourquoi toutes ces relations là existent.
Troisième technique de manipulation : le piège de la cohérence.
Alors ça c'est rarement fait par hasard quand même de la part du manipulateur
qui va commencer à vous poser des questions
qui n'ont pas un rapport tout à fait direct.
Ca parait flou en fait par rapport à ce dont vous êtes en train de parler, ou l'argumentaire.
Surtout qu'en général les questions vous savez qu'il connait déjà pertinemment la réponse.
Mais vous répondez quand même.
En fait il est en train de vous amener à une cohérence
pour vous amener à une démonstration,
que vous pensez ceci ou que vous pensez cela, alors que c'est pas la cas.
Ca c'est quelque chose que l'on sent vraiment arriver.
On sent qu'il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas
On sent qu'on nous force à donner des réponses pour les exploiter plus tard
et en général le manipulateur est plus à l'écoute, et relance avec beaucoup de questions.
quand vous sentez ça arriver, n'hésitez pas à donner votre réponse en complétant.
Vous donnez cette réponse là car c'est ce que vous pensez évidemment sur ce chemin de manipulation
c'est quand même ce que vous pensez vous à ce moment là.
Et vous complétez en disant : mais je vois où tu veux en venir,
je sais ce que tu veux me faire dire, ça n'a pas de lien avec ce dont on est en train de discuter.
Mais donnez la clé à la personne en face
que vous avez compris là où il essaye de vous emmener
et que ce n'est pas la peine de perdre du temps avec ça.
Un peu en rapport avec le 2 et le 3,
il y a la technique du faux choix.
C'est à dire que l'on va simuler un choix
Enfin le manipulateur va simuler de vous proposer un choix.
Mais parmi ce choix il n'y a qu'une seule proposition d'acceptable
les autres sont parfaitement inacceptables.
Mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas d'autres choix, d'autres alternatives,
mais présenté comme ça on a l'impression qu'on à la choix qu'entre A, B et C,
le manipulateur veut nous forcer à prendre C
et pour ça il va faire en sorte de créer un A et un B complètement fallacieux et inacceptables.
Par exemple, pour les vacances tu préfères qu'on reste à la maison à rien faire,
ou alors qu'on aille à la mer,
ou qu'on se galère à essayer d'aller dans les montagnes,
pour faire des randonnées, sur des refuges où on sait même pas si on a de la place pour dormir...
Qu'est ce que tu préfères ?
En forçant comme ça la personne à répondre parmi ce choix
on essaye d'occulter qu'il y a plein d'autres possibilités
que celles que la personne nous émet.
Cinquième technique de manipulation qu'on voit pas mal en ce moment
avec les politiciens et c'est pour ça que ça me fait penser pour vous en parler.
C'est la technique de l'anti calomnie.
La personne va dire quelque chose où l'on ne veut pas être inclus en fait dans le début de sa phrase,
on ne veut pas subir la calomnie qu'il est en train de prononcer
et du coup on va le suivre.
C'est le genre de phrases qui commencent par
si on est vraiment quelqu'un d'honnête, alors on ne peut que .. bla bla bla bla.
Ou dans le même style, il y a vraiment que les gens un peu stupides ou en qui on ne peut pas faire confiance
qui diraient que ceci, ceci, cela.
Vous voyez un petit peu le chemin qu'on emprunte là.
On ne veut pas, surtout pas, être inclus dans ce sac de mauvaises personnes.
Et bien ça c'est la technique de manipulation q'on appelle l'anti calomnie.
Quand vous détectez une manipulation en face il y a des solutions hein,
les deux solutions les plus intéressantes c'est d'ignorez et poursuivre
vous faites semblant de ne pas avoir été atteint.
De toute manière vous n'avez pas été atteint
Et vous répondez comme si de rien n'était, vous ne répondez même pas à cette technique de manipulation.
Donc faire un petit peu l'idiot en répétant votre dernier argument,
la dernière chose que vous avez dite vous le répétez ou vous le reformulez,
comme si la personne n'avait pas compris et que du coup il y avait un petit quiproquo.
C'est une manière élégante de casser la manipulation et remettre le débat au bon endroit
ou la conversation au bon endroit.
Sans traiter l'autre de manipulateur car encore une fois je vous rappelle que souvent il y a des manipulations qui sont complètement inconscientes.
D'ailleurs il ne faut pas voir les manipulations partout hein,
après il y a le fait d'essayer de convaincre les choses.
La manipulation c'est un grand mot comme ça qui fait peur.
Voilà pour ce nouvel opus sur la manipulation.
Je reviens sur le côté on est 200 000 maintenant
plus de 200 000 sur cette chaîne, sur le mental vlog que j'ai lancé le 1er janvier 2016.
Donc 333 jours après, moins de 11 mois après,
on a passé les 200 000 personnes qui suivent ça, c'est ouf !
Je tenais sincèrement à vous remercier, j'ai une petite surprise pour vous,
on s'était fait un trip d'ailleurs pour le passage des 200 000 avec Max.
Ba on va pas mentir, on a gagné !
C'était la vidéo de samedi, il y en a qui ont adoré le délire
il y en a qui ont détesté ça.
Nous avec Max en tout cas on s'est bien marré à le faire,
et c'était un chouette clin d'oeil auprès de nos abonnés.
Une vidéo un peu différente sur les 333.
Alors pour vous remercier, car encore une fois pour l'instant je ne m'en remet pas.
C'est à dire qu'il faut savoir que le 12 octobre on faisait le meet up pour les 100 000 abonnés,
le 12 octobre dernier.
C'est pas si loin que ça !
Et ça me donne une patate pour continuer, je vous raconte même pas !
Mais je m'égare... Pour vous remercier de ça,
je suis en train de créer un petit jeu, un petit quelque chose qui va vous permettre de mentaliser les gens autour de vous.
il va me falloir encore quelques jours pour finir de le créer, de l'imprimer etc.
Mais c'est quelque chose que je veux vous offrir à vous,
aux abonnés de la chaîne qui me suivez soit depuis le départ,
soit qui m'ont découvert il n'y a pas longtemps.
Mais peu importe, le but c'est que ce soit un vrai cadeau
donc que ce soit gratuit et que vous ayez ça parce que vous êtes abonné
et que du coup vous regardez cette vidéo jusqu'au bout.
Mais forcément comme je veux que ça reste gratuit, ça va me couter une blinde si je vous les envoies tous,
surtout si vous êtes 200 000 à le vouloir.
Ça ferait beaucoup !
Ça ferait beaucoup mais je le ferais !
Mais pourtant je voulais que ce soit un vrai cadeau physique
Alors j'ai trouvé la solution, je vais mettre un Google Form dans la description de cette vidéo,
sur ce Google Form vous vous inscrivez
et d'ici quelques jours juste avant que le jeu soit prêt,
je vous enverrai un mail avec une adresse.
A cette adresse là vous enverrez une enveloppe timbrée, avec votre adresse à vous.
Timbrée avec un timbre normal, un timbre rouge si possible.
Une enveloppe format A5, c'est à dire une enveloppe comme ça, de cette taille là.
Vous mettez donc un petit timbre ici, vous mettez votre adresse,
vous enverrez ça à l'adresse que je vous enverrai par mail
et si j'ai 200 000 enveloppes à envoyer, je le ferais ! Je prendrais des gens pour m'aider, mais je le ferais !
J'espère bien sur que cette idée pour célébrer ce cap ça vous fera plaisir
autant que le plaisir que j'ai eu en regardant le compteur bouger hier soir.
Merci beaucoup d'être là !
Si vous n'étiez pas abonnés avant cette vidéo, merci d'avoir rejoint la chaîne
et vous pouvez cliquer juste ici
et vous pouvez aussi participer il y aura aussi un cadeau pour vous.
Et le mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour depuis le 1er janvier,
depuis 333 vidéos, mais ces vidéos elles n'existent que parce que vous êtes là pour les regarder !
Merci beaucoup, rendez-vous demain à 17h, Ciao !
*musique d'outro*